this is only his second start at home
this year last five starts have come on
the road and he's been brilliant he won
his first game here um in progressive
field and didn't allow a run uh he's 4-0
in his career folks against minnesota
and that fine start he had earlier in
the year 3-2
swung out of this he chased a ball that
was nowhere
near the strike zone
that's a cricket style swing right there
i think that bounced in front of the
batter's box it did
and there's another one and wait those
screws yeah and wasted no time three
pitches and a good at-bat for jose
ramirez and he lines a single down the
left-field line so a good start for the
indians there goes ramirez throw to
first ceno's throw down is not in time
and it skips away arise but backing it
up perfectly was polanco give him a
stolen base that's number seven there
goes ramirez for third throw nowhere
near in time
and how about jose ramirez stealing
faces on back-to-back pitches
hard hit ball in the hole a two-out rbi
single for carlos santana and the
indians will play from in front tonight
as santana has his 15th run batted in on
the year
and the indians are now
seven for their last 16 with two outs on
the homestead comes a rise and bieber
himself has given the twin a scoring
chance here and now the 1-0 picture
swinging a line drive left center field
that's the base hit towards the alley
cino's gonna round third and score
digging for third gonzalez at eyes to
second base that's an rbi double and
it's a one-one game but there are two
out in a one-one game first and third
ahead 2-0 and the pitch is swinging the
line drive into right that's a base hit
scoring is at eyes jeffers will hold at
second base a hitter's count kepler
doesn't miss it rips an rbi single and
the twins take a 2-1 lead a two-hour
walk pushes reyes in the scoring
position that's the tying run and
domingo santana coming to the plate he
struck him out
and hill pitches around a two-out single
and one
fly ball out to the third baseman and
here is nelson cruz the 2-2
swung out and missed why not
why would she not continue to do it
if he's going to keep swinging at it i'm
going to keep throwing it and that's
exactly what bieber has done here
tonight that's seven strikeouts yeah
and it's been the same pitch every time
up and here is cesar hernandez lefty
hill rocks and delivers slow curve got
another slow breaking ball
and hernandez so he strikes out the side
three up and three down
nice job rich hill miguel opens up the
inning two walks and a run scored now
the one two
swinging a mess good slider bieber
strikes out his eighth swing gonna miss
got him with a curveball
nine strikeouts for shane bieber there
it is his tent strike out of the ball
game he strikes out the side here in the
sixth so a leadoff man aboard here in
the sixth and frankie lindor coming to
the plateau for two
lindor liftoff deep right field kepler's
back he's out of room it's out of here
it's a flow ball
hit it out onto the tarpon right field
and lindor
with a two run homer here in the sixth
has put the indians on top three to two
and boy is he jacked up santana in the
scoring position one out here is tyler
naked with a bat for jordan luplow
and there it is down the right field
line that'll get into the corner that'll
plate another on santana scores naked
into second base with an rbi double and
it's a four to two indians advantage two
on one out twins down two seventh inning
if you're facing polanco you'd rather
face them on this side of the plate
that's that's my guess here
right to third ramirez bobbles it steps
on the back goes across the diamond
santana what a job what a play by carlos
santana and oliver perez gets out of
trouble with another double play the
second in his many nights
brad hand looking for his eighth
save of the year
and he'll have the bottom third of the
minnesota order due up
the 1-1 from brad hand
marlon gonzalez drills it to center
delano the shields back to the track
makes the catch just shy of the wall one
away
now the 2-2
strike three called outside corner
fastball
it looked like a rise was looking slider
and he just couldn't pull the trigger on
the fastball
twins are down to their last out two
down in the ninth with the indians on
top by a score four to two
blooped right field charging in naquen
he calls for it makes the catch
to end the ball game
and the indians snap a four-game skid to
the twins by winning
the middle game of this series 4-2